you're listening to episode 2 of the
stronger by science podcast in which
Gregg knuckles tells us about his recent
study comparing fatigue and recovery
rates between males and females we've
also got an interview with dr. Jason
kaliba who is a professor at Coastal
Carolina University and we spoke with
Jason about betaine supplementation the
state of research and Exercise Science
and the state of higher education as a
whole now before we begin I have a
little announcement
we recently spent months revamping the
online coaching program it's stronger by
science and we're finally able to open
up some one-on-one coaching spots we are
running a one-week sale starting today
May 30th we've got a really talented
coaching staff and I am stoked that our
new and improved coaching service is
ready to roll so if you've been thinking
about signing up with a stronger by
science coach now would be the time to
do it because the sale ends on June 6th
and finally the first few minutes of
this episode has some spoilers for
Avengers endgame and for the final
season of Game of Thrones so if you want
to avoid those spoilers just look at the
timestamps in the episode description
and you can skip ahead to the segment
called
feats of strength all right that's
enough announcements enjoy episode 2
welcome if you are listening to this
that means two things you made it past
our very unlikable sarcastic sense of
humor in episode 1 and decided to try
another it also means that you've
forgiven Greg for his last-minute
misogyny at the end of episode 1 he
apologized to me and his family
profusely for that or they just didn't
listen to episode 1 or they just didn't
listen yeah with which All Things
Considered is most likely that is the
highest likelihood so anyway we're glad
to have you for episode 2 and this is
quite a momentous day for the stronger
bioscience family because I have the
opportunity by the way I'm Eric Trexler
your host I have the opportunity we're
off to a smashing start so far I have
the opportunity the honor to be the
first person to present master Greg
knuckles now Greg defended his master's
thesis
yesterday successfully and he's always
been a master to me because that's just
his management style but but now it's
official
so I so Gregg is still a temporary host
still on his kind of probationary period
he made some big mistakes episode 1 but
we're gonna give it another shot but
Gregg welcome thank you um I don't think
I'm actually I don't think I have that I
don't have the degree yet do I you do
not yeah I I don't know how that works
I I can fill you in you're you're being
a little in temperent here well it's
it's kind of like if you're a knight you
can make other people a night because I
have a PhD I can kind of make anybody a
master I think I'm the I'm the Brienne
in this situation is that a sport do we
have - spoiler alert that I don't think
so I mean it's been it's been like a
week and a half and this will be up in a
couple weeks anyway yeah so yeah I was
gonna say that but I was like let me
generalize that that situation uh that's
a game of Thrones reference if you're
listening and have no idea what we're
talking about but anyway so what happens
is when you've completed all of the
degree like for a PhD except your
dissertation defense then you're you're
abd I don't think there's an equivalent
for that with the Masters unless for
some reason you did the whole degree and
we're delayed on the on the defense part
mm-hmm which that actually does happen
now that I think of it so you're kind of
like all but dissertation or all but but
thesis or whatever then after you're
there so you've done all the
requirements of the degree and you've
defended whatever thesis or dissertation
you're doing then you're called a
gradual and like okay nd at the end and
so it's not a graduate but it basically
means you did everything you're supposed
to - you're supposed to do but
graduation day hasn't come yet I see so
I the only reason I know that is because
I had to send out some manuscripts and
like sign cover letters in that little
waiting period and I was like Who am I
and that's how you are right now you
were are a graduate of a master's
program I'll take it so and then
once the degree comes in the mail it'll
be official denied and I will be a
Master of Arts you will be an artistic
master yes that's a weird thing about
our masters is that it's a Master of
Arts not a Master of Science yeah so so
for people listening if you've ever
looked at Eric's CV and you see that
it's ma PhD and mine will soon be ma as
well the reason why the exercise
physiology program at UNC is a Master of
Arts and not a Master of Science is we
don't actually take that many classes
and I think the way the university
determines whether something is an MA or
an MS is how many science classes you
have to take like for the actual degree
program and so UNC is is fairly light on
the academics to give the students more
time to be in the lab and actually do
science so ironically like it's a Master
of Arts so we can actually do more
science yeah and if everyone I talked to
no one has cared yet that I'm not a real
scientist cool I've got uh I actually
have a bachelor's in education a
master's in art and then my doctorate is
in philosophy obviously yeah a PhD
that's what the pH stands for so I
haven't figured out science yet I
haven't cracked that nut academia is
weird it is a strange place with a lot
of very elaborate robes and hats now how
do you feel different now that you're
almost a master not really other than
that you're doing good yeah did you like
Avengers the other night we went out
with a big group of people and saw it it
has to be it must have been like kind of
opening night right uh opening night was
we saw like five days after opening I
was still really crowded yeah so also
for people listening
Erik came and saw Avengers with us he
had not seen any MCU movie up to this
point so I imagine he was very confused
but you know there was there was like
some some stuff that would make more
since if you knew the characters better
but like most of the cool parts are just
the action scenes anyways yeah I I had a
good time but it's like it's kind of
like if you go to jaws 2 and you're
sitting there and it's like oh I didn't
see jaws 1 somebody can nudge you and be
like dude really big shark yeah you just
are just to fill you in the shark is the
bad guy here alright so with this one
it's like instead of not seeing the
first one I haven't seen the first like
16 22 22 that's even worse and so at the
beginning my girlfriend was kind of
nudging me and trying to give me back
stories as we went and I kind of just
called her off and was like there's
really no point here cuz like the
superhero backstories are insane it's
all just like so here's the thing he can
fly at night but not during the day his
main thing is he's lactose-intolerant
that's gonna be big when they have a
scene and like the cheese processing
plant and he also got his heart broken
and that's like this whole thing is he's
trying to avenge that yeah every single
character had like a 30 page backstory
so I just you know I mean really but
really all you need to know is purple
man in bed yeah I picked up on that yeah
a very very very bad man but no it was
good I so I thought it was good I
actually preferred infinity war if I'm
being honest which you haven't seen so
that doesn't mean I don't have an
opinion I need to you fair enough
yeah I don't know I felt like I like
chose with stakes and it felt just very
like happily-ever-after
type deal like there were some not to
spoil it but like there were some some
key characters that died but if you've
been following Marvel movies like even
if you didn't know the plot of in-game
you knew those characters were going to
die because their contracts with Marvel
Studios were up and they were like yeah
now I want to go act in different things
and like broaden the base of projects I
work on it's like you already knew who
was gonna die
not me I was on the edge of my seat
fair enough didn't care but I was the
only on the edge of my seat anyway I
thought it was good I thought that
season 8 episode 3 of Game of Thrones
was better though yeah that was pretty
crazy yeah well like we we saw those on
back-to-back nights and I think if I
would have seen in game with that game
of ferns episode not fresh in my mind I
would have been like whoa this is
awesome but it kind of paled in
comparison being honest yeah I agree
and we all we also had somebody over for
that Game of Thrones episode that had
never seen I guess he had seen one Game
of Thrones episode before that and and
it was only the prior episode that was
all exposition yeah so he was as lost as
I was during Avengers but I think we
both had a good time anyway yeah
now we haven't done this segment yet but
I think this is a perfect week to do it
the segment is called feats of strength
and we had a couple a couple big ones
this week and you brought both of these
to my attention so I'm gonna let you
have the honors here yeah so if if
you're listening and you follow power
lifting you probably know about both of
these already but if you don't who buddy
they're crazy
so Jon hack recently totaled 1962 at 181
that was via a 677 squat 501 bench and
782 deadlift to to the best of my
knowledge John is still drug-free and if
that's the case that makes this even
crazier and even if it's not I don't
care because it's still an absolutely
ridiculous total so for my money the
previous most impressive raw total of
all time probably was Jessie norris's
2033 at 198 and so to be you know
basically 70 pounds off that in the next
week class down
that's wild like I honestly think that
in terms of like male raw powerlifting
that may be the most impressive total of
all time for my money yeah and like to
your point you mentioned like drug or no
drug you don't really care no the only
thing because I've competed at 181 yeah
the only thing you could make me that
you could do to make me total that would
be if you did like a singularity thing
and just merged my skeleton with a
forklift or something like there's
there's no amount of drugs and wishful
thinking on the planet you know yeah so
you this was pretty humbling for me cuz
like I I'm a reasonably good power
lifter and my ultimate goal in this
sport is I'd really like to total 2000
at 220 and potentially 2100 at 242 and
like like I said like I'm not a scrub
power lifter not at all and and I'm
basically aiming to do what John just
did but to weight class is higher and
that and and those would be numbers that
I'd feel like okay I can die happy now
yeah dudes just on another level like
that that's a ridiculous total you know
I had that kind of number in my head we
both have the matter or the privilege of
having gotten into the sport before all
the strong people did true my thing that
I really wanted to do and this is
embarrassing in hindsight I was gonna be
thrilled to squat 500 at 181 mmm-hmm and
I was like that'd be a really nice
number for me yeah man that's something
people miss though like back in the day
if if you were sub 200 and you had a 500
squat we were like oh that's a strong
dude no like when I did that at the
state meet in Ohio in 2012 I was like
you know I kind of puffed my chest out
walking down the hallway yeah and people
were like oh that guy had a hell of a
squat this he squatted 677 he benched
501 yeah like that's really really scary
yeah a 500 squat ed 181 these days is
probably good for like 30th place at
national yeah it is that
it is not not good but and then the
other one which I thought this one was
even more ridiculous but Mariana Gaspar
Ian squatted 573 so that's two hundred
and sixty kilos at 123 which was that
was raw with knee wraps Mariana is not a
tested athlete I would be shocked to
find out if she were drug-free but again
that does not matter to me one iota
because that's that's our ridiculous
number that's 4.7 times body weight and
it's actually it's actually like 20
pounds over the male world record in
that weight class which I don't think
that's literally ever happened in any
strength sport ever
yeah and equally impressive it's not
just the squat both her and Steffi Cohen
broke both the men's and women's world
record for the total in that way class
as well this past weekend but just that
squat man like that's that's an
outrageous squat
yeah I'm it's crazy and we were just
kind of going over those total records
and I think you said four of the top six
in that weight class for untested
federations were women across all
Federation across all favorite yes okay
and I mean I'm sure a big chunk of that
is there just aren't that many men who
weigh 123 but it has to yeah yeah yeah
but especially on but but still like
even so just the fact that there are men
who compete in that weight class in
general like the sex difference in
strength is so large that no matter how
good a female lifter is she may be
better than the vast majority of men in
the world but typically there's a pretty
big gulf between
the top men and the top women in any
weight class so we mentioned John hack
at 181 earlier the most impressive
untested woman in that class is Shakira
Ingram formerly Shakira Holcomb and
she's absurdly strong like I don't want
to downplay this at all like she's an
unbelievably impressive lifter she
totals close to 1600 at 181 untested
which like that would be that is a lot
of weight yeah and that would be a very
very competitive
men's total yeah in that weight class
but you know hack is out totalling her
by close to 400 pounds yeah so for
Mariana and Steffi to both break the
men's world record at 123 regardless of
the fact that there aren't that many men
at 123 like that's still absurdly
impressive yeah it's crazy and you
mentioned you know those strength
differences between men and women is
that something you know a little thing
about one or two things
so I mentioned Greg defended his thesis
yesterday and I was there in the flesh I
thought he did a great job I took notes
so we'd like to discuss that a little
bit while it's fresh on the mind
so Greg can you tell the listeners kind
of the just that the topic first yeah so
I was looking at fatigue ability and
recovery rates between men and women
right and you know I thought your
presentation was awesome you started out
by kind of highlighting some of the
differences between men and women when
it comes to both fatigue and recovery
from strength training and strength in
general I think you mentioned as well do
you mind going over some of those for us
yeah so the the relevant physiological
differences when it comes to fatigue
rate is women on average tend to have a
higher proportion of type 1 muscle
fibers it's it's hard to know how
relevant that actually is I'm not aware
of research saying that like
you know if you have 10% greater
relative abundance of type one fibers
you will be X percent less fatigued able
but type one fibers are a little less
fatigue well than type ii fibers so that
is a physiological difference whereby
one would expect women to be less
fatigued Abul on top of the fiber type
differences due to the effects of
estrogen primarily women have different
patterns of substrate utilization so at
any relative exercise intensity women
have a slightly lower reliance on
anaerobic metabolism and a slightly
lower reliance on glucose metabolism
which means like you're gonna burn
through glycogen a little more slowly
you don't accumulate lactate and
metabolic wastes quite as quickly
etcetera so that's a relevant difference
and the final thing which which prior to
this study i thought may have been the
most important thing was just women have
smaller muscles than men again not in
all cases but on average and one of the
things that occurs when you're
contracting your muscles pretty hard is
they increase like if you flex your
bicep it increases in in circumference
like the muscle itself and so that's
going to put pressure on the blood
vessels that run through the muscle and
so larger muscles are going to put a
greater occlusive pressure on veins and
arteries which could limit oxygen
delivery and waist clearance and so
they're thinking they're being okay
women have slightly smaller muscles
they're they're going to have to be
using their muscles harder to exert the
same amount of occlusive pressure on
their blood vessels so just oxygen
delivery waist clearance may be a little
bit more efficient in terms of
differences that may be relevant for
recovery again it probably mostly comes
down to sex hormones so estrogen helps
to stabilize the sarcolemma and
decreases macrophage infiltration of
damaged tissue a little bit if that
sounds like
complete gobbledygook essentially what
it does is it helps prevent some degree
of muscle damage like muscle damage
still occurs but after a given relative
stimulus women will have a little bit
less like disruption of the actual
muscle fibers themselves and limiting
macrophage infiltration that essentially
means less swelling less edema less
inflammation within the muscle so it
should recover a little bit quicker and
not have like greater secondary damage
due to like a very large inflammatory
response and then as far as recovery
goes estrogen helps with basically like
all stages of the lifecycle of satellite
cells so activation differentiation
proliferation and then donation of my
own nuclei to the muscle fibers so that
should improve recovery but also
testosterone does the exact same thing
so it's hard to really say that that's a
sex difference like it's a sex
difference that women have more estrogen
but men also have a sex hormone that's
doing all of the same stuff um so yeah
those are those are most of the key
physiological differences that would
lead one to expect that there might be
differences in fatigue and recovery yeah
I like how you say you say would lead
one to expect there'd be a difference
because the worst kept secret in
exercise science is that we basically
built an entire body of literature only
studying men right yeah and so now
there's a lot of a lot of interest in
saying what about the other half of
humans yeah you know do these things
really generalize and so now there's a
lot more effort being put toward
venturing into essentially building a
new literature from scratch you know
well not not necessarily building a new
literature from scratch but but kind of
seeing how much we know about men does
actually generalize to women right and
so one of the things I I've always
pushed for the idea that there are
several really pressing research
questions where where there's very
obvious reasons to say I'm not sure you
know what we've been generalizing for
men
women I think there's good reason to
think that that's not a safe
generalization and so I've kind of
gotten into arguments where it's it's we
need more of this female research but we
need to prioritize what's done in terms
of like do we have a strong rationale
for why there would be a difference yeah
and I think it's very lazy to say well
it was all done in men so let's just do
like one-to-one replications of every
study out there like that would be
essentially rebuilding a literature from
scratch yeah but I think in the short
term it's really important to do a
targeted approach to like what are the
most realistic you know pressing
research questions where we think there
would be a difference and kind of attack
those first before we start building out
from there for sure so I think this is
one of those really solid research
questions where as you've just discussed
there's a very strong foundation for why
a person would expect that fatigue and
recovery are different in men versus
women there are mechanisms that would
underlie such a difference but now it's
time to actually do the research and
find that out so in your literature
review were there any like really big
gaps that you saw that that kind of
reaffirmed your idea that like yeah this
is the study that needs to be done now
uh so as far as fatigability stuff goes
the biggest gap is just there there are
actually a lot of studies there but most
of them use protocols or measures that
wouldn't really be relevant to most
athletes or coaches so like probably a
solid eighty percent of that research
just uses isometric exercise which is
good for being able to tease out
mechanisms because the muscles just
they're in place doing a contraction
against an immovable force basically so
so isometric meaning that the muscle
length doesn't really change they're in
a contraction so like doing a wall sit
or just kind of stationary like flexing
of a muscle right and they're isometric
so yeah that stuff is interesting but
it's hard to know how well that's going
to actually pour it over to you know
doing something like squat or bench
press or 90% of the exercises we would
do in the gym the isometric literature's
indicates that women are less fatigued
able than men but again it's hard to
know how well that that'll actually
generalize to like normal training then
of the research that does actually use
dynamic resistance exercise it's a lot
of the models they use don't reflect
what I think a lot of people care about
in practice when they think the Teague
ability so the most common ways that
people will go about addressing the
question is like just take one set to
failure at a given percentage of one rep
max and see like okay like strength
endurance you know can men or women do
more reps at 70% of their max over one
set most of that research finds that
there's not much of a difference but
also I don't think that that's the type
of stuff most people care about they're
more interested in like you know when
I'm prescribing volume over an entire
session for a male lifter versus a
female lifter should I expect to need to
prescribe more volume for the man versus
the woman and then probably the second
most common experimental approach is
just to like do three sets to failure or
something and see total reps completed
over each that going to failure correct
correct which again that that kind of
resembles like a traditional
bodybuilding approach but that's not the
way most strength athletes would train
most of the time you're not going to be
taking literally every set to failure so
it's hard to know how well that
generalizes as well so yeah as far as
fatigue ability goes there's a fair
amount of research but it's hard to know
how applicable most of it is and then
for recovery most of the research that
exists only uses eccentric exercise
there's a good reason for that so if
you're just trying to induce muscle
damage in a lab setting you ISA Theory
exercise causes way way more muscle
damage than concentric
so that's the reason it's used most
frequently but the problem with that is
that literature is probably biased
against women so most people know this
but your muscles can produce more force
eccentric ly than concentrically and the
eccentric to concentric strength ratio
on average is higher for women than men
so if you're doing something like you
know like sets of 10 at 80 percent
maximum eccentric force or something
like that that may be you know around 1
rep max force for men but it may be like
120 percent of one rep max force for
women because they have a higher
eccentric to concentrate strength ratio
and yeah like again you have ecological
validity issues because that's just not
how most people typically train you're
just only doing these Centrex and just
for content context eccentric sar when
you're loading the muscle as its
lengthening so basically doing like
negatives yeah yeah I get heavy negative
so yeah a lot of this literature is you
know I semi isometric or eccentric only
which close to nobody is really really
training that way correct yeah and then
of of the research that uses like normal
dynamic exercises like the type of stuff
we would typically do in the gym most
studies just don't look at performance
outcomes and the ones that do if they're
monitoring recovery of strength tend to
just use isometric measures or just look
at an isolated muscle so you know half
people do squats and then see you know
how is their knee extension strength
changing over the next three days
instead of like how is their squat
performance changing over the next three
days as they recover so yeah with the
with the fatigue stuff generally the
experimental protocols don't look the
way most people train and with the
fatigue stuff the actual protocols they
use tend to be a little more similar to
how most people would typically train
but the things they're looking at to
assess recovery generally aren't the
type of stuff that most athletes or
coaches would care about so what I was
aiming to do with my study wasn't
necessarily to you know be the first
person to look at male versus female
fatigue and recovery but to do so with
an experimental model and recovery
assessments that are the type of things
that most people listening to this would
actually care about right yeah so it's
one of the great things about you've
probably seen this as well there's a lot
more people I see that are really into
lifting that have spent years and years
and years under the bar that are getting
into research and kind of higher
education in the field mm-hmm and I
think the more we see that I would
speculate there's gonna be more people
like you who come come along and say we
can still answer this research question
and maintain some of the ecological
validity you know the more we have
people that care about the ecological
validity I think the more we're gonna
see those types of designs we we were
talking about this yesterday I don't
think it would be the worst idea in the
world if there was like a stipulation
where you know before you before you do
like performance type research at least
get a couple people strong like like
show that you understand the the actual
stuff that like the people who are going
to be applying the science well enough
that you can do science that will
actually affect practice in some way
yeah or like you know if you're gonna do
like weight loss weight loss stuff in
like the sports nutrition space at least
like get someone shredded right like
like show you understand that world well
enough to do research that's going to be
relevant to it and and so like if you're
purely just doing research for other
scientists and just looking at like pure
physiology stuff yeah whatever it
doesn't matter but if you're doing
research that you like want it to be
useful for practitioners do some
practitioners stuff to understand like
what would actually be useful to you if
you are in that world or get a
practitioner involved yeah or that
assigns level yeah you know I mean we
always talk about like bridging the gap
between science and application
but there's not a lot of people who
actually like crossing that bridge and
and getting the other side involved yeah
you know yeah yeah I knew a great
scientist
his name's Erik Silva loose key I lived
with him actually and we had a prowler
in our living room he just had this gift
where he would accumulate strength
training equipment it just followed him
around he had like a storage unit full
of like squat rack pieces and prowlers
and stuff mm-hmm but he told me the
quote I'll never forget is if you can't
measure it in pounds it's not worth
measuring he also told me that if he
ever started a lab he would have like a
special quotient he would calculate that
would include a potential students
powerlifting total and their GRE score
because he didn't want people that were
either too weak or too smart so he kind
of had this like Goldilocks zone in the
middle that compared their strength and
their their standardized testing scores
I said I feel like that might be taking
a shade too far but it's mostly joking
but it's got the right spirit it's got
the right spirit
so you mentioned like you're not the
first person who's thought what if we
compare the sexes in fatigue or recovery
but you as you've kind of alluded to the
devil's really in the details and yet
somehow the study is put together and
what the methods look like so can you
give us kind of the very brief
description of how you went about
answering that question yeah so each
participant came six times first visit
was just face line testing fill out some
questionnaires get a DEXA scan arm Lee
Mass was the primary thing I cared about
from the DEXA and then at the end of
session just work up to a 1 rep max and
wow working up to a 1 rep max we got a
load velocity profile and and we got
that so we could then subsequently
estimate 1 rep maxes so essentially what
we did is we did sets of
three at thirty forty fifty sixty
seventy and eighty percent recorded the
fastest rep of each set and then from
there that load velocity profile so if
you graph like x-axis is percent Weber
at max Y axis is mean concentric
velocity the relationship there is going
to be like stunningly linear the average
r-value in my study was like 0.99 three
which is and that's on a sail from zero
to one correct
so so that high that's that's quite good
and so then when you work someone up to
a one rep max you see how fast they move
the bar at one rep max and so from then
on essentially what you can do is you
only have to work someone up to 80% you
plot their load velocity profile as
they're working up to 80% and then you
can extrapolate that trend line down to
the velocity that they move one rep max
loads and get a pretty accurate
estimation of their one rep max reason
we did that was for monitoring recovery
because you know I don't want to just
have people benchpress and then test
isolated elbow extension strength on a
dynamometer like I wanted to have an
idea of like okay like how are people's
actual benchpress is recovering but
obviously I don't want to put someone
through a fatigue protocol take them to
failure and then immediately after say
all right we're gonna max again and
tomorrow you're gonna max again day
after that you're gonna max again and
day after that you're gonna Mexican as
well yeah I didn't want the the recovery
assessments to basically turn into the
Bulgarian method right is what I'm
saying
and that's that's both for a participant
safety and also to make sure I'm getting
good data because if I want to see how
people are recovering from a fatigue
protocol I don't want the testing of
recovery to induce a lot of additional
fatigue which would then cloud the
assessment yeah I would have found no
one ever recovers under any circumstance
correct that was your Protege we we see
after a fatigue protocol you're weaker
the next day what do you know you're
even weaker the day after that all right
three days post
40% of people are injured and no one
recovers yeah interesting and because
you have no actual weight trading
experience you would then conclude in
the literature apparently no one's ever
recovered from a training session before
true now lifting is a hazard to society
yes anyway so that's what the load
velocity profiles were formed and so
then in session 2 same stuff a session 1
but no DEXA no questionnaires they just
came in worked up to a 1 rep max got
load velocity on the way up and then 5
minutes after they hit their max strip
it down to 75 percent of their max and
just have one set to failure the reason
for that is to see how well just single
set strength endurance could predict
fatigability over something that
simulates an entire training session so
the fatigue protocol itself was on
session 3 so to start with we're people
up to 80% get their load velocity
profile then go back down to 75 percent
and do sets of 5 with 90 seconds between
sets just until someone reached the
point of failure so set a 5 for us rest
90 seconds from the time they rack the
bar to the time the unrack it again set
a 5 for us 90 seconds etc then got blood
lactate pre and post and 10 minutes
after they failed during the fatigue
protocol just get their load velocity
profile again to see how much they've
very very acutely fatigue then days 4
through 6 very straightforward come in
work them up to 80 percent load velocity
profile and then gave them
questionnaires to assess soreness and
sleep the previous night so just asking
how long did you sleep subjectively how
was your sleep quality and then how sore
are your pecs triceps and front delts on
a scale from one to a hundred basically
and that was that awesome that and you
also took a lot of a lot of like
background demographic information as
well right just just to make sure you
had all your bases covered yeah so so
the questionnaires themselves were
asking about sleep stuff so we use the
Pittsburgh sleep quality at
inventory index whatever PS Qi and for
stress we use the perceived stress
questionnaire both of which are
validated questionnaires to get an idea
of both the quantity and quality of
someone's sleep and then how how
stressed someone perceives that they are
basically and then I had another
questionnaire I made that was just
looking at training background so it
asked how long you've been lifting in
general how long you've been bench
pressing how many sets of bench press
per week do you do how many times per
week do you bench press what proportion
of your sets of bench press are fewer
than five reps what proportion or
between five and fifteen reps what
proportion are greater than 15 reps how
long do you rest between sets of bench
press and what your general training
goal is for the bench press is it
primarily to build muscle gain strength
or to improve strength endurance yeah
and looking at that questionnaire I
think that's where it really showed that
you are a person with experience in the
area where you're using that to inform
you know yeah what you're looking for in
the stair at least what you you've
thought to account for yeah because if
two people have three years of training
experience and you know one person is
like me and I'm doing like a lot of
heavy triples with five minutes between
sets and someone else is doing sets of
twelve with sixty seconds between sets
so they're like me yeah like we may have
like the same years of training
experience but the actual adaptations
that would lead to probably considerably
different um so yeah I wanted to see if
the way people habitually trained would
affect their fatigue ability or how well
he recovered from training yeah and
speaking of what you did end up with a
pretty well trained and pretty strong
sample right yeah yeah so average years
of training experience was like 7.2 for
men 6.2 for women the men did have a
little bit more experience with the
benchpress itself basically men for the
most part started benching day one in
the gym which is very unsurprising yeah
most of the women had about two years of
resistance training experience before
they touched the bench press so they'd
been benching about four and a half
years on average we got pretty well
trained I I checked their IPF's course
to see whether like the the male and
female samples would be similarly
competitive in the actual context of
powerlifting because like that's what I
care about
III can say very confidently without
doing any searching you're the first
person to do that
no people use evoke scores a fair amount
what yeah okay yeah I can see that yeah
this may be the first one with IPF y
axes the IPF things new right yeah I
mean is will if I would have used folks
the results would have been the same
right um but yeah so the average IPF
points for for the men were like 434
using like the benchpress specific
formula and for the women was like 460
so very very similar and just to
contextualize that like what the IPF
formula does is it it basically crammed
everything into a normal distribution
also accounting for weight and sex such
that the mean of the distribution is 500
and in a standard deviation is 100 so
with IPF points in the mid 400s
essentially they the people in my sample
were not as good of benchers as the
average competitive power lifter which I
wouldn't expect them to be but they were
mostly within one standard deviation so
they would have been at home in a
powerlifting meet but not particularly
great power lifters yeah so pretty good
average male bench was like 230 average
female bench was not quite 135 like with
for the last participant it was like 2
pounds under 135 so I was hoping that
she was gonna be like super strong and
pulled average above 135 just because I
think that would be cool because the men
did did crack the to play barrier but
she wasn't super
so yeah it was like 1:29 or something
yeah but you you know that's pretty good
yeah so I've had the privilege of
actually seeing under the hood a little
bit when it comes to the results and the
data which I'm sworn to secrecy on but I
by the way never would have imagined as
a you know as an 18 year old kid who's
like oh maybe I'll study exercise
science that we find ourselves in a
place where we get to like run studies
and actually like handle data and stuff
like I see no it never gets old to me
that we can like do cool studies we care
about and actually be that person a few
years later where you're just hanging
out with your friends like looking at
your data
oh yeah that's pretty crazy I agree now
can you give us a rundown of basically
the the key findings I mean I just
listen you talk for like 40 minutes
yesterday about results alone so I
assume you don't want to share all of it
but like the key findings in your mind
so during the fatigue protocol women got
way more reps like basically twice as
many and that's doing the repeated sets
of five until they until they fail three
so so total reps completed during the
fatigue protocol there's like somewhere
around thirty four men somewhere around
sixty four women
so big difference recovery so assessing
recovery via predicted one rep max and
soreness of the pecs triceps and front
delts recovery assessments were all
similar between sexes so in spite of the
women doing way like almost twice as
many sets they've recovered it
essentially the same rate as the men did
and that was actually what I
hypothesized and in terms of like non
significant differences which whatever
like do with that what you will the
women like twenty four hours post
training were a little more sore than
the men
but that wasn't a significant difference
but there there decrease in predicted
one rep max 24 hours post was actually a
little smaller than it was for the men
so like strength recovery actually may
have been slightly better for the women
and but soreness may have also been
slightly greater for the women but again
like those differences weren't
significance at home don't like go
posting around the internet like Oh Greg
said this he has research to prove it
like no that's dumb and then all of the
various things we looked at to see if
you know if like sleep would affect any
of this stuff or stress or training
background pretty much nothing was
predictive of anything um
the so for soreness 24 hours post
training the men who got more reps
during the fatigue protocol tended to be
sore than the men who got fewer reps
during the fatigue protocol that
relationship did not exist for women
basically like one person got 24 sets
and the fewest number of sets someone
got was three so that like big range
there but that wasn't predictive of how
sore people got at all which I thought
was interesting and the only other
factor as far as fatigue goes the only
factor where when you put it in a model
also accounting for sex that also
significantly contributed to predicting
how many reps people would get during
the fatigue protocol was bench press
sets per week so like training volume
such that when even accounting for sex
people with higher training volume
tended to get more sets during the
fatigue protocol
I think that's reasonably intuitive yeah
other than that though how long someone
had been training like how good of a
bench er they were like IPF points what
their training looked like wasn't
predictive of how fatigue while they
were or how well they would recover
which I thought was I personally felt
that was quite interesting yeah
so you know we kind of started this
conversation talking about how you
approached it from a very applied kind
of perspective you know viewing the
research question but setting up the
study with a lot of ecological validity
that theoretically should facilitate
application of the findings so what do
you think are kind of the applicable
takeaways for somebody who wants to use
this to inform their training moving
forward it's hard to say the reason it's
hard to say is so essentially when you
run a study you have to come up with a
protocol that you think is going to do a
good job of testing whatever it is you
want to test for some things the the
validity thereof and the
generalizability is very obvious so if
you want to know how strong someone's
bench press is he work them up to a max
that's how strong they are on the bench
press like that's not really a debatable
thing when you're dealing with a
construct like fatigue ability I think
my protocol did a pretty good job of
assessing that but you know the protocol
is what it is and so the actual like
magnitude of the findings we know
applies to the bench press using the
protocol that I used but you know if
variables were manipulated so if we used
a weight other than 75% or if we use
different rest intervals or if we used a
different exercise results may have been
different so I think I feel pretty good
saying that for upper body exercise if
men and women do submaximal sets with
similar rest time between sets women are
probably going to be able to do more
sets than men and recover at a similar
rate as far as the recovery stuff goes
my findings actually contrasts with a
recent study by Davies at all that had
women men and women do five sets of five
squats at 80 percent and then one set to
failure and found that for some measures
men actually
a little faster than women looking at
counter-movement jump height and
concentric knee extension strength so it
could be that maybe women recover at the
same rate or for a given level of volume
slightly faster for upper body but maybe
men recover a little faster lower body
devi study was quite ecologically valid
as well like I wish they would have
actually assessed squat strength
recovery instead of like knee extension
strength but overall that was that was
quite a solid study so yeah like we need
more work to flesh out some of those
details but I feel good saying at least
for the benchpress and probably upper
body exercise in general women can
probably do more volume or at minimum
men need longer rest periods between
sets like those those I think would be
the two solid takeaways that I'd feel
the best about and then if you wanted to
generalize a little bit more I do think
women on average are a little less
fatigue able than men but that would be
a pretty big generalization just from my
study specifically I do think when you
look at the entire context of the
literature you can support that but I
want to draw something that brought just
from my one study yeah and luckily
people are gonna get their own
opportunity to interpret your work right
I mean yeah yeah what are you planning
to do with it moving forward um I'll get
it published
I'm hoping as digis academic journal
probably not I mean so I'm not aiming
for like msse or something like that I'd
really really like to get it published
in peer Jay like that's my number one
choice reasons being I'm I really
support the open science movement yeah
and you've put your name behind it yeah
yeah like so I definitely want it to be
open access I don't want it to be in a
journal that generally isn't open access
but like you know we'll publish an open
access article from time to time like I
want to support a journal that does
specifically you know throw its weight
behind the open ax
movement and pier J's good and its
publication cost is lower than some of
the other options and and and they
publish good stuff so that's my first
choice but then like another reason I
like pier J is they say you can talk
about your results and share them
literally however you want it has a
Creative Commons BY 4.0 license which
basically says you know your your
results are completely in the public
domain
as long as someone gives you credit they
can use it however they want and like I
think that's how science should be so if
prj will take it that will also mean
that I can do a thorough write-up for
the site without like Elsevier trying to
sue me right and that the damnedest
thing yeah suing you for writing about
your own work yeah and so when you say
the site that would be stronger by
science com yeah so hopefully someday in
the near future you'll be able to get a
thorough write-up and that'll give Greg
you must have spent some some long
nights doing all those kind of
additional exploratory analyses that
were quite informative but you know may
or may not make it into you know the
peer-reviewed manuscript yeah so that
that would be a good a good kind of
avenue that you could still pursue those
things and get them out there yeah for
sure
so time flies but it looks like it's
just about time to play us out here
alright now to play us out I was gonna
hit you with a very generic but very
timely question so the whole body
building strength world it used to be a
world of mythology mm-hmm it was just
oral traditions handed down from
generations of strong people and in the
last probably 10 15 maybe 20 years
there's been this push of taking a more
evidence-based approach to how we train
how we eat things like that and I think
an extension of that is there are more
people who really like fitness who are
getting into
higher academic programs so pursuing a
bachelor's even a masters sometimes even
a PhD in the field so the day after kind
of finishing your master's when you look
back at it for someone who you know
maybe they're about to start college or
maybe they just finished a different
bachelor's degree and they are thinking
about pursuing a master's in the field
what what kind of advice would you would
you give someone in that position
whew biggest piece of advice would be to
not do what I did a master's program
shouldn't just consume your entire life
but if you're trying to get a master's
while also trying to run two businesses
it probably will so I I do think I think
a good time to get a master's would be
fresh out of undergrad or if you want to
work for a couple years get a job that
it wouldn't kill you to walk away from
for like while you're in grad school the
the path I took is not one that I would
recommend and then just in general if
you want to pursue it like there there
are there are several careers where if
you don't have at least a master's
you're gonna have a tough time so these
days like strength and conditioning not
so much private sector I don't think but
especially if you want to work for
college or a professional organization
most of them are looking for a master's
degree so like if that's something you
think you want to do definitely need to
go to grad school for it if your this is
kind of out of left field but one thing
I would say is I think it's important to
distinguish science as an instrument
from
the state of the literature in the field
as it currently is as Eric alluded to
there there's a lot of really good
research that is getting published from
people who either have some experience
coaching or you know work closely with
coaches and generally know what they're
doing so they're they're putting out
research that's going to be applicable
for practitioners back in the day there
was like the stereotype that I was
scientists are just nerds and like
pencil-neck nerds and lab coats that
don't know anything and like that is
probably true in some cases but there
are absolutely people who understand
strength conditioning well enough that
they're publishing very good very
applicable research so I I wouldn't want
you to be dissuaded just by that
negative stereotype and think like oh a
lot of literature doesn't seem to be all
that useful and relevant therefore this
isn't the place for me if you find a
good advisor who will kind of let you
take your applied knowledge and do good
work with it science is absolutely an
instrument that is flexible enough to
allow you to do research that is going
to give people a lot of benefit and
utility and then in terms of whether you
particularly should do it I guess it
kind of depends on what you want to do
in the industry I mean if you want to be
a professor like you need to obviously
right if you kind of want to do if you
just want to be like a personal trainer
or like a strength coach at a private
facility I don't think I don't think
it's the worst idea to get a master's
but a PhD would would be overkill and I
think I think the value of a master's is
that you learn information in undergrad
but you don't learn that much about the
actual scientific process and how it all
works and I think that if you're someone
who cares about science and like the
quote-unquote evidence-based approach to
training people and whatnot or just
training your
you do get more of like a depth of
understanding of science if you have
actually done it versus like the idiots
who just read PubMed abstracts and think
they know anything about anything so I
think that will help give you a little
bit more depth there can I give a quick
quote in that regard sure I don't mean
to derail you but yeah when I was
applying for masters programs out of
undergrad I asked for a recommendation
letter from somebody and he I was a good
undergrad student I mean I you know I
would obsess over the material and get
it and then give it back on exams and he
said I know you're a very good undergrad
student but that doesn't mean you're
gonna be a very good grad student yeah
because when you go from undergrad to
graduate work you transition from being
an information consumer to someone who
synthesizes and hopefully produces new
information and so he said never forget
that what you're doing is a complete
transition yeah this is not an extension
of undergrad yeah it's exactly what
you've alluded to the idea of looking at
current research and synthesizing new
ideas from it or even creating your own
original research from scratch you know
I mean or even if you're not doing that
just generally if you wanna if you want
to understand what the research in a
field is saying you kind of need to know
how to read research and to read
research it helps to have done research
so you you know what's going on or you
know you can see behind the page a
little bit as you're reading correct and
just to have to like be forced to read
research and have your understanding of
said research checked by your adviser
and other professors like to make sure
you know what you're doing and not just
like completely jacking up your your
interpretations cuz man like there's
some there's some wild stuff that people
come up with that they say is based on
science where it's like bro if you
actually knew how to read a [ __ ] main
script would realize how dumb this idea
is yeah and so like I think I think a
lot of that is coming from people who
mean well but don't have any like
graduate training or formal education in
the space and so like their good-faith
efforts are still terrible efforts yeah
I mean I'm not going to you know she'll
for the ivory tower academic structures
but I think it takes a very unique
person to be able to take the sell the
purely self-taught approach mm-hmm and
navigate it effectively because as you
mentioned it's not just exposing
yourself to the material but sometimes
your genuine best attempt at
interpretations are off base yeah and
when it's entirely self-guided there's
no one there to correct your course and
say that was a good attempt but have you
considered this different mm-hmm angle
at it and yeah and you know I started
grad school with thinking I was quite
brilliant and came out feeling much
dumber and it was because I received
plenty of Corrections along the way but
from from really smart smart people who
set me on the right course yeah and I I
definitely feel like I understand
research in general much better now than
I did two years ago yeah another thing
that you didn't mention that I'd like to
throw in there so I've been within the
University walls for the last like six
years which means every year I there's a
new group of undergrads interviewing in
our department and I'll always sit down
and they'll say ask for advice about
graduate school and stuff one thing to
keep in mind if you're thinking about
pursuing a master's in the field is that
the amount of variability between
masters programs and our field is
enormous yeah in terms of what you're
gonna get so there are some master's
programs that are super applied you
might even be automatically assigned to
work as the strength and conditioning
assistant with one of the athletic teams
you may never see or even hear about a
research project happening in those
hallways yeah the other side I think
the program we graduated from is the
complete opposite where you can't throw
a rock without hitting a different
research study there's like six labs
down the hallway and they're all working
you know 12 14 hours a day around the
clock so many studies going on but if
you went into that master's program and
your main goal was to get hands-on
experience coaching athletes you would
have come out of that and been probably
unpleasantly surprised by the amount of
avenues for exposure to athletes yeah
and even within a program like that the
the the variability in what what you
will study in your lab that like the
other students are doing or what your
adviser is doing and also like what you
will be allowed to do for your own
research is also very very fast great
points so like my advisor is actually
like he was in he is an exercise
oncology guy and so we had like mostly
breast cancer research going on in the
lab had had a schizophrenia study we
were helping out with and so like the
research that I assisted with like
that's the type of stuff we were doing
but then me and the other master's
student he gave us the leeway to do
projects for our thesis that we actually
cared more about so she looked at the
effects of different crank links on
different like performance and gas
exchange variables for cyclists which
has nothing to do with cancer but dr. B
is like super cool and was like hey you
want to do this school do it and I just
looked at bench press which again has
nothing to do with cancer but doctor B's
chill as hell and so he was like this is
what you want to do you're passionate
about it absolutely let's do that and
not every advisor will give you that
leeway yeah so you know if you're out
there searching for a program obviously
like Greg mentioned think about is that
something that's going to really be
necessary or or help you you know get
closer to what you want and then really
think carefully about what kind of
program and and kind of who's the right
fit for an advisor and hopefully that's
some helpful information
out there big piece of advice I would
give is if if you want to apply to a
program definitely reach out to the
advisor first make sure that you know
they know your name when your
application crosses their desk they'll
be like oh I've interacted with this
person before they seem decent and you
know talk to them about how your
experience in their lab will be but
don't take that at face value also talk
to the current graduate students who are
in their lab because some advisors are
very forthcoming very straightforward
and what they tell you about what you
can expect from their lab is exactly
what you will get from their lab
sometimes they're somewhat like
salespeople and you'll get kind of a
more a more accurate view of what
actually goes on in that lab from the
graduate students so yeah talk to your
prospective adviser but definitely talk
to their current students as well yeah
and as Greg mentioned maybe think twice
about running two businesses while you
do your masters yes
Greg is a tremendously humble guy once
more I want to congratulate him on
finish finishing his master's and
somehow managing to run a couple
companies and you're still married
correct I think so and maintain a
marriage during the whole process I
think that says more about Lindsay than
it does about you oh absolutely
no no question to close out episode two
we've got a great interview with dr.
jason khalipa
so stay tuned and enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the interview portion of
today's podcast this is Eric Trexler
stronger by science director of
education Gregg is unfortunately not
with us today he is collecting data like
every good scientist does but we are
very lucky because today we have Jason
Cole Eva he's a professor associate
professor at Coastal Carolina University
you might be saying who's Jason Cole Eva
you do recognize his name you probably
saw it on a paper and thought it was
chole WA but Jason thank you for joining
me today the fire pleasure thanks for
having me on so Jason and I go back when
I was looking at graduate schools he was
one of the people I reached out to and
at the time you were at Kentucky and so
I went out there for the interview
process I was talking to one of the
faculty members and they were like yeah
we know you've been talking a lot with
with dr. Cole Eva and I was like I I
think you got the wrong guy I've never
met a kleva like I was certain that your
name was chole wa so me and this faculty
member we're having like parallel
conversations and I thought they had me
mixed up with a completely different
person
so Jason four people surely people have
seen your work in the peer-reviewed
literature can you give us a little
introduction you know kind of what your
background is what you do now of course
well how far back do you want me to go
as far as you'd like don't don't you
know not deepest darkest secrets but
whatever you want okay
well right so academically my
undergraduate is actually in
communications with a focus on marketing
and I realized pretty early on out of
school that I really did not enjoy much
that had to do with with marketing and
sales and I had always loved training so
I decided to become a personal trainer
I was very good training people that
were like myself so if you were a
meathead and you wanted to become more
of a meathead
I was your guy but then I got this
client who was 80 some odd years old and
she had just had a stroke and I felt
completely clueless and helpless and I
decided to go back to school to take
some classes nah matriculating to learn
a little bit more and much like
everything else that happens in my life
I got a little carried away and ended up
getting a PhD in Applied exercise
physiology from Springfield College so
that's kind of the backstory to to where
I am now I'm currently an associate
professor at Coastal Carolina University
were a small school in in South Carolina
and I also do some some online coaching
in addition to my professorial duties
yeah yeah that's kind of a common thread
on our podcast we tend to bring people
on that arm their primary appointment is
being a meathead and they they kind of
moonlight by doing science or you know
training people so you did your PhD at
Springfield College and the the topic of
your dissertation was betaine correct
yeah that's correct so can you give us a
little bit of a background on betaine
like from me like I've done a lot of my
supplement research on some of the heavy
hitters caffeine creatine nitric oxide
stuff the things that are kind of front
and center
I feel like betaine has kind of been
hanging around the periphery of the
supplement world for a while can you
give us like a brief background about
what it is and kind of I guess it's kind
of how it entered the scene betaine is a
common name for trimethylglycine so you
have a glycine with three methyl groups
attached to it and it was first
discovered in beets and that's where
it's got its name and it's rich and not
only
only beats but also green leafy
vegetables like spinach and kale and to
a lesser extent in in wheat as well as
in some shellfish as well when I was
looking for a topic for my dissertation
I knew I wanted to do something with
regards to sports supplementation and
how it affected strength and body
composition and so I was looking for
something novel to study I kinda want to
be to be different and not go the the
route of some of the compounds that had
been more heavily researched and I saw a
couple studies that were done what
you're saying is you wanted your lit
review to be very difficult yeah
actually I saw some studies that were
done and in regards to performance and
the first study I found well I should
back up a second and when I write my my
review of literature's I like to collect
all the studies and before I even read
any of them I like to put them in
chronological order to try and better
tell the story of of whatever I'm doing
a lit review on or researching and so
the first study I found was done in
polio patients back in the 50s where it
improved some metrics of performance and
then there wasn't really a lot until the
study came out and horses that was
actually done a UK veterinary and then
there were some studies in like 2008 or
9 that showed some improvements in
performance
obeah they were pretty contradictory
some showed improvements in power while
others showed improvements in muscular
endurance and the ones I showed benefits
on Empowered didn't show muscular
endurance and vice-versa but we really
got me interested as I was researching
it as I saw all this work that was done
in animals specifically pigs and broiler
chickens and in pigs they've been using
it for at least a decade as a dietary
additive to increase meat yield and
reduce the subcutaneous fat which I
thought was really interesting if it's
improving body composition and pigs
maybe it can do this in humans the only
one other study had had looked at it at
the time and that study had done it in
obese individuals who were not
exercising and so most of the studies in
pigs were were young pigs that the
stress of the bones growing put a stress
upon the muscles and that maybe resulted
in a little greater adaptation and then
one study I found and there's a lot of
these studies actually coming out of
China they love to research betaine and
in livestock and they found that pigs
that were given these pens to move
around in kind of free-range pigs I
guess if you will saw greater
improvements in in mutton meat yield
than then pigs that were confined to a
very small pen so that's kind of what
gave me the idea to to do my
dissertation on on trimethylglycine or
betaine and and see how it might impact
changes in body composition associated
with resistance training yeah I love
this idea I've never thought of bulking
as trying to increase my meat yield so
so you want to help these you know young
college-age people increase their meat
yield had anybody looked at hypertrophy
up to that point or was it all just kind
of functional performance outcomes it
was almost all performance outcomes
physical performance outcomes there was
one study that that did measure body
composition that wasn't in the obese
subjects but it was very short in
duration I think it was like two weeks
in duration and there was no no training
component with it so it was untrained
individuals yeah so okay so you got this
idea you've you know you did your lit
review say okay this might have some
been
fit for body composition lean mass you
know body fat performance you had a
performance component too right yeah
one RMS and a vertical jump and then
tracking the amount of volume that was
occurring during training as well okay
so in a nutshell I mean what did you
what did you end up finding we found
improvements in lean mass improvements
in reductions in fat mass and but no
real performance benefit there was a
decrease in the vertical jump of the
subjects taking the placebo but there
was no increase in in the vertical jump
of the betaine subjects we also looked
at the lean cross sectional area of the
arm and the thigh and to do that we did
girth measurements and then took skin
folds at the quadrants to give an
estimation of a lean cross sectional
area and so saw a greater increase in
lean cross sectional area of the other
arm than of the thigh interestingly in
one of the big studies I found they
found greater increases in the hams than
in the butts in the pigs so that was an
interesting little tidbit to try and
prove that my defense yeah so okay and
that was I mean what was that like 2013
ish yeah okay so what I like to do we
bring on people who do research you hear
every researchers say like you know what
one studies just one study you know you
don't want to make all your conclusions
based on one paper and then with
interviews people are like to spend 45
minutes telling me about one study
please so as a person who study betaine
who's kind of seeing the literature
evolve what's your current status in
terms of B Taine's applications like do
you think there's a useful role for it
for people that are interested in
supplementing to increase muscle lose
fat enhance performance maybe
it's a great question the we did a study
a couple years ago and we looked at the
interaction between betaine
supplementation and resistance training
and young women and we found an increase
in in a reduction in fat mass compared
to placebo but no real clear
improvements in lean mass or or rectus
femoris muscle thickness compared to
placebo and also no improvements in
performance again measured with one RMS
and vertical jump so I think it may have
a slight benefit in regards to increases
in lean mass and maybe a slightly
greater benefit in regards to reductions
in fat mass and now this is all
molecular studies coming from animals so
take it if you will but in in pigs and
chickens betaine suppresses lipogenesis
and and increases AMPK mRNA expression
so it may help someone to lose fat in
that regards but this hasn't been
replicated in humans so if your goal is
to increase your strength your 1rm it's
probably not all that helpful we're
gonna look at it hopefully in CrossFit
athletes in the fall to see again to add
more data to the body composition
outcomes but to see if it does improve
improve strength endurance in terms of
muscle mass it's a really powerful ozma
light and so to give you an idea when
when I was doing my dissertation I had
two capsulate all the all the treatments
and all the placebos I had to make like
9000 capsules or something like that
with a little captain quick machine
going 50 50 capsules at a time and and I
was doing it and I and this was in April
in Connecticut so it's not crazy humid
like it is in the
the Carolinas but I stepped away I took
a break and I came back and there was a
little bit of beat saying that had
spilled maybe like half the size of a
penny on the table and I came back and
it was just a pool of water and so I was
like that's interesting so every time I
would make it I would leave out like a
little a little bit of betaine and and
come back and see what happened and
every time I came back it it it was just
water sitting there so that's probably
what's happening within the muscles as
well is that it's drawing water into the
muscles kind of kind of like the same
way that creatine volumizes the muscles
and maybe that is beneficial in terms of
in terms of strength endurance or in
terms of creating a more hospitable
environment for for a protein synthesis
but that's yet to be seen
so I mean currently do you see betaine
being included in a lot of supplement
formulas on the market like I don't
think I know anyone that specifically
uses betaine as a single ingredient you
know are you familiar with a lot of
people using it or maybe adding it in
like pre-workout formulas or anything
yeah which is interesting I think now
food sells a trimethylglycine and and
and then there's the beta power which
comes from Dupont nutrition though I'm
not sure if that's available on the
retail market or just as a wholesale but
most of most of the trimethylglycine
that I've seen is is in pre-workout
supplements which usually the dose is a
little bit lower than then what we've
used in the studies and and also it's
not wait wait wait wait wait you're
telling me that a pre-workout formula is
under dosed for something never I don't
believe in those formulas that have 60
ingredients and the scoop is like 10
grams of actual weight I don't believe
it
yeah I'm sorry go on I'm just being a
smartass we can go down that road as
well but by anyway you were saying
you see beating some of these I see yeah
I see you in like in the multi
ingredient pre-workout supplements and
there's a gazillion of them on the
market and and usually it's it's not at
least in the doses that we've studied
it's usually about half that dose and
and just like beta alanine which is also
usually under dosed and those products
it's a it's a supplement that I don't
think acts acutely I think it's
something you need to take for like two
to four weeks and allow it to accumulate
in the tissues to exert its effect
unfortunately unlike bid alanine you
don't get the paresthesia so you're
probably not going to get the sweet
placebo effect yeah
so one time I was in a kind of like an
undergraduate lab class it's weird I
actually told the story last night with
Greg and some friends but it was like an
undergrad research methods class so we
did like a little pretend lab like just
to learn how studies work and we were
trying to figure out well what should we
do for this little pretend study and I
was pushing really hard like let's do a
little beta alanine thing like we can
get the doses for cheap and you know
it's you know it'd be quick and easy and
we could do a little experiment and a
lot of people were a little hesitant but
just by like sheer force of will I like
insisted that our class was gonna do
this the TA actually accidentally gave
us like I think it was about a 10 gram
dose like he had messed up like the size
of the scoop and and so every kid in
this undergrad class is just like acting
like they're wearing a suit made of bees
like we're all falling out of our skin
and everyone's looking at me like hey
Eric thanks for huh thanks for saying we
should do this but in my defense it
could have been worse
because I heard that like a couple years
ago in a similar scenario they
accidentally gave a bunch of students
like 30 grams of caffeine did you hear
about that no yeah I forget where it
occurred I think it was across the
Atlantic somewhere but I forget they're
trying to do a real study or just like a
little in-class kind of experiment but
they accidentally they intended to give
300 milligrams and they accidentally
gave like 30 grams of caffeine and
fortunately nobody died but like I think
two of them had to go on dialysis like
very acutely but yeah it was so it could
have been worse is the moral of that
story Wow even three grams of caffeine
is if if you have three grams you're
gonna have a bad day if you have 10 you
could die if you have 30 you probably
should you know I mean have you ever
taken niacin on an empty stomach
only in a big multi ingredient formulas
where I couldn't really suss out exactly
what was the niacin the way you didn't
get the flush right it was like the only
times I've had nice and I think they
were included and pre-workout so I was
getting the beta alanine and the
caffeine and the niacin so it's kind of
hard to tell what's what you know what I
mean yeah I talked about niacin and
sport nutrition and one of my students
came back one time the next day and told
me he took niacin and said he thought he
was gonna die because he got this huge
niacin flush and he said it was a
combination between like the beta
alanine tingling and really bad sunburn
[Music]
all I could do is laugh yeah yeah the
thing with beta alanine is and niacin
it's like if you don't see it coming and
nobody warns you like yeah you could you
could take a real heavy scoop and be
like okay so this is it for me
but now you have you done some research
on pre-workouts themselves because i
know you talked about it a lot I've seen
you talk about it at conferences and
stuff I have a have this one ongoing
project currently is is on hold as they
work on our labs but one of the things
with with pre-workouts and really the
entire market of pre-workouts and all
the research that's been done on
pre-workouts is they've all been
compared to a placebo and so you have
the issue that you alluded to with some
of the active ingredients being under
dosed but then you also have a very
large dose of caffeine in these products
and caffeine is herbal genic and in most
instances for most people and so when
you're comparing it to placebo it's not
really telling you whether that product
is any more effective than taking a 15
cent caffeine tablet and it's not
telling you whether any of those other
ingredients are acting or go gently or
herbal Italy so actually reducing the
effects of caffeine within that product
and so that's something that's kind of
been bothering me over the past like
three or four years is all these studies
that compare pre-workout to a placebo
and okay the pre-workout is safe and
another study comes out and comparing
another pre-workout to a placebo and
looking at heart rate and blood pressure
and energy expenditure and it's not
really giving us in the scientific field
any any information it's not new it's
not novel it's not really uh not really
beneficial so we're doing a little kind
of pet project comparing this this one
pre-workout supplement against equal
dose of caffeine against the placebo and
the the manufacturer was was kind enough
to to get
bored with this study and and provide us
with the pre-workout as well as the
caffeine and the placebo to to kind of
put put his product on the line to see
if it is any more beneficial yeah I mean
that's gutsy because you know I've been
in when you write about creatine or
caffeine or beta alanine you have to at
least address the pre-workout literature
and most the times I've had to do that
in a manuscript I say hey there's this
pre-workout stuff but I don't know like
there's like 35 ingredients I can't
really make a determination about what's
going on there but that's cool and it's
cool that they're willing to put their
product on the line like that you know
and me and say I think that this
combination of ingredients is more than
just caffeine yeah absolutely
it's a smaller smaller brand label
they've only got a few products but they
do a pretty a pretty thorough job of
kind of vetting what they're what
they're putting into it yeah I remember
back in the day it was like it a thing
where people that were into supplements
were getting their own caffeine powder
just like pure powder I I don't know if
you could still do that because I know
people have overdosed on it and died
unfortunately I'm not sure there's a we
have the pure caffeine powder and in a
digital scale and when the person who's
blah or who's running the blind of the
study so I don't know what people are
drinking and they don't know what
they're drinking it's a double-blind
study but when she when she puts
together the the treatments she wears a
a little like nurses mask when she's
dealing with the caffeine yeah I used to
always it would just shock me and a
teenager I'd spent so much money on pre
workouts and then one time I was like oh
I'm gonna get some caffeine powder which
I don't recommend by the way if you
don't know what you're doing with your
caffeine powder okay for real like
people get it mixed up with their
creatine and a creatine sized dose of
caffeine
powder will mess you up so don't do it
however I did it and it was just
incredible like you get like a lifetime
supply of caffeine for like $30 but
you'd never see the end of that supply
of caffeine when you get it in powder
form but again that's not an endorsement
so this you're talking about blinding
and stuff in different experimental
protocols that kind of segues nicely you
guys recently had a poster and a
manuscript that came out about
statistical reporting and exercise
science can you tell me and the
listeners a little bit about that
project well it was Conrad earnest
brainchild I don't want to take too much
credit for it it was it was his idea and
something that he had been noticing and
when you look at the peer review process
for for publishing any manuscript at
least in our field I can't I can't speak
to two fields outside of exercise
sciences for nutrition but they're
pretty vague there's there's really not
each journal doesn't have instructions
as far as what to look for in terms of
evaluating statistics of the whether it
was appropriate or not and it's kind of
left each editor and an each reviewer so
there's a high level of autonomy which
which can be both a good and a bad thing
but essentially what what we noticed was
a lot of the stats were being reported
incorrectly so generally when you report
statistics when you report like
characteristics you report the mean and
the standard deviation and when you
report change variables you report
confidence intervals associated with
them what we found was people were
reporting the mean and they were
reporting the standard error which is a
which is not the correct variance
statistic to use it very much under
estimates or gives an impression of a
much lower
variance and the and the data collected
yeah if the readers not paying attention
they might interpret it as a standard
deviation and and it would look like a
very small standard deviation exactly we
were finding some papers that reported
no no variance statistic at all a lot of
papers weren't reporting effect sizes or
weren't reporting the correct effect
sizes a lot of papers we're not putting
forth a primary hypothesis or any
hypothesis any directed hypothesis at
all the other thing we found was there
really wasn't any difference between
what you would consider a high tier
Journal in our field and and more of
it's called like an entry level general
yeah in terms of these errors and
statistical reporting yeah so I mean you
know I've always been really interested
in stats and my disclaimer is interested
does not mean good you know like I don't
claim to be an expert statistician I
just think they're important and I think
the more researcher expands that skill
set the more effective they can be so
these types of papers are remarkably
helpful what do you think is the the
root cause of this what why why is
statistical reporting not more
universally understood and why are the
guidelines not kind of streamlined and
standardized
I'm not totally sure to be honest it's
it's curious why more journals haven't
adopted the the consort paper which kind
of lays out how you should report your
statistics some of the journals we
submitted this paper to actually quite a
few rejected are our paper and said it
doesn't apply to us or whatever so I'm
not sure why were they correct no they
had you know we we had scrubbed their
day and this was just for one year this
was just for the the 2017 calendar year
so yeah we had described many different
databases or many different journals and
just went through one at a time and and
we were only focused on sport nutrition
trial so anything that had some sort of
performance or body composition outcome
related to to sport nutrition or sports
supplementation yes so basically the
journal didn't want to publish a thing
saying that they looked kind of bad yeah
I guess so
or or maybe they genuinely don't have an
interest you know to be fair it could be
absolutely so one of the things that's
tricky my girlfriend is doing her PhD in
psychology and psychology is a field
that has very much embraced quantitative
sciences so her department has a whole
branch of people that are just
quantitative psychologists like they
develop new ways to do stats and I think
one of the things that encourages that
is that they have sample sizes to play
around with so in the sport nutrition
exercise science literature a lot of
times you have studies that are
remarkably low in sample size and so if
you have a small sample size you can
have the most expansive statistical
skill set in the world but you can't use
any of it
you know an immune like that there's not
enough statistical power to actually
implement some of these more
sophisticated stats and I have a theory
that that's one of the reasons that the
education that an exercise science
student receives in statistics is
generally not that great I think as a
field from the top down we've never
really gotten that into it you know what
I mean yeah I totally agree just looking
at my own personal education and in
doctoral statistics it's interesting
that you say that - because I'm reading
this book right now called the undoing
project and it's related to some
psychologists back in the 70s from
Israeli psychologists and and kind of
tearing apart at these these different
theories they had back then and how it
really was the Wild West but yeah a lot
of a lot of the studies are either
underpowered
or or have a very low low sample size
and so you are really limited and what
kind of statistics that that you can run
there's also not quite as much modeling
that's happening I think in in Sport and
Exercise Science as there are in in
psychology I mean yeah it's the thing
that I found is a lot of exercise
science programs at the graduate level
don't really have a lot of really high
level stat courses within department and
if you want those you often have to go
out of department and one of the issues
is that you might be learning stats that
because they're teaching mostly to
students kind of within their wheelhouse
it's not super applicable you know so
like if you I remember one of the stat
courses I took was quite good but start
to finish a full year of coursework we
never got to repeated-measures analysis
so basically the entire spectrum of what
was learned only applied to independent
groups study designs we don't really
have a ton of pure independent group
study designs with no repeated-measures
in sport nutrition exercise science so
it's tricky I think I think sports
science benefits from papers like yours
that say hey we have a standardization
problem and sports science benefits from
papers like the big paper that came out
with stork about kind of improving
transparency in methodology and sports
science I know like Andrew Vygotsky was
was pushing that hard and I think Gregg
was part of that as well but I mean
these are good things you know these are
not catastrophic the sky is following
things of like oh the fields in shambles
these are good things they're they're
people proactively saying hey let's try
to standardize some things so that we're
all speaking the same language and let's
make sure that our language is actually
valid yeah I agree
you know challenge will will create
positive adaptation and that's certainly
something that that we need in our field
I have my students do an article review
as part of sport nutrition in relation
to each select the dietary supplement
and because none of them know the
difference between a peer-reviewed
article and a block and furthermore none
of them can really know the difference
between like a systematic review or
meta-analysis and some sort of clinical
trial or trial I have them clear the
articles with me first and I give them a
little bit of feedback on it on how to
understand it and so there is such a
huge just wide range of methodology that
I see in terms of I don't know complete
reporting of the methodology versus
leaving a lot
a lot of questions especially in some of
these journals that aren't indexed in
PubMed that they somehow find articles
from yeah I mean it's an interesting
time no I used to do a similar exercise
with my students but it was not an
exercise science course
so I'd let them pick paper from whatever
field they wanted and the the range of
methodologies this is obviously expected
to be broad but even just the there are
certain fields that if you aren't fully
conformed to their agreed-upon
standardized methods in reporting not a
chance it's just not gonna get through
and some fields I'm very close friends
with somebody who's a statistician who
has worked in multiple fields you know
he's a pure stat guy so whoever hires
him that's the field he's in and he said
a similar thing happened in the field of
Nursing Research he was involved with it
I think for at least a couple decades
and then he said from when I started the
analytical approaches the methodological
reporting it was just a night and day
difference from the time I entered the
field to the time that I moved on so
fields grow up at different rates and I
think exercise science is that kind of
right at the start of a very positive
growing phase and it kind of coincides
with a more global thing right like I
just saw the University of California
system failed to renew their journal
subscription to Elsevier like there's
all these big rumblings of change when
it comes to the publishing process how
universities do academics you know how
much how much people will start
transitioning toward maybe online
education Xand how do we deal with the
costs and the return on investment of
higher education like I feel like
there's a lot of things that are kind of
converging right now when it comes to
science and education my question to you
as somebody who's in higher education
where is
this going do you have any positive or
dire predictions for the near future I
don't know about predictions but I've
definitely made some some observations
seem to be pretty backed up by more
experts in regards to analyzing higher
education and so I think the return on
investment it's a really really good
question we currently live in a society
where it's kind of viewed that college
is a college education is the answer to
all of our economic woes and economic
discrepancies or inequalities and I'm
not sure if that's the the answer and
I'm not sure if that is true especially
not for everyone it seems like college
for the students is a thing that they
have to do that they feel is you know
the first step in in their life that is
kind of pre-scripted if that makes sense
yeah it's like it's like the 13th grade
right you finished 12th grade in high
school and you go to 13th grade it's
just what you do that's kind of what it
seems like and a lot of them don't
really have any any passion and anything
that they're studying I would say a
coastal 50% of our exercise science
students don't even exercise not they
don't train not they're not competing
but they don't even exercise and so
trying to the degree is kind of a means
to an end because it knocks out a bunch
of useful prerequisites basically
something like that yeah
and as you're aware the cost of college
has gone way way up and I can assure you
it's not because the faculty are getting
paid more much like everywhere else in
education you know we're asked to do
more
bless but the the amenities of of all
these schools is really what is driving
up this this cost that's higher
education so and I hate to sound like a
salty old man but I remember an
undergrad you know we had a very small
dorm room with with two beds in it that
we can either bunk or half separate and
that was how we lived and now the the
dorm rooms are becoming much more
luxurious a lot of times you have
apartment Styles where you don't have to
we don't have to share a room
coastal has essentially subbed out most
of their their living to contractors and
so they have tools and tiki bars and
it's outrageous
it looks like a comic resort it really
is and I don't want to just pick on my
institution because it's it's everywhere
LSU just put in a lazy river in the
shape of LSU that cost them millions of
dollars so all these colleges are
competing to get more students and and
one of the ways they're doing it is by
offering more amenities and we're not
just talking about physical amenities
like this but but non-academic
departments and then all the
administrators that have to run all
those departments and then all the
insurance and stuff that that goes into
it as well so all that's driving up the
cost and it's probably not going to
change until students and parents start
realizing that's really what they're
paying for
and and demanding a different model a
lot very well could go to online
education it's a lot cheaper to to offer
a course online than a brick-and-mortar
course kind of kind of getting
sidetracked off this but probably most
of the students in college don't need to
go to college and could do something
else that they find that they find
interesting I love education I think
education is important to provide people
with the thinking skills and the
knowledge to better interpret the world
but I don't know if the cost is going to
justify at all and I don't know when
that tipping point is is gonna be ya
know it's an interesting question you
bring up the idea of a new model and I
feel like it's analogous when it comes
to higher education and academic
publishing is that we are locked into
models that were established a very long
time ago and they've always been how
publishing or higher education works
like this is the system and what we're
finding is that we might not necessarily
need those systems to be the way they
always have been so things like online
education online open access publishing
that doesn't require the costs of
printing we're seeing that technology is
kind of forcing us to encounter these
decisions where we're kind of locked
into these systems but if we made the
system today would we design it the same
way and if the answer is no then that
probably means we could make some useful
revisions you know yeah what was the
last time you you picked up a printed
journal like not printed an article that
you downloaded online to highlight and
write on but actually like a periodical
right yeah no it happened um I was
cleaning out my office after I graduated
and there was some dusty old rags in the
way it was like an M SSD copy from like
the mid 1990s when I was like 4 years
old but no by the time I got into the
world of caring about journals that was
already done like that was I've never
actually gone to a librarian or a friend
or a mentor and said do you happen to
have a hard copy of this journal laying
around it's never happened in my life
yeah everything is online which is which
is great and there's more and more and
more publishers and it seems I don't
know what came first the chicken or the
egg the you know the pressure to publish
more frequently and higher volumes and
and then more publishers and going back
and forth but I just wonder some of the
real seminal scientists maybe some like
physicists how how many publications do
they have on their video like some of
the people that we really think about in
physics
obviously Einstein is is one but wah and
all those people and then in exercise
science Karpovich and some of the people
from Auburn way way back in the day how
many publications do they have that are
really impactful and and really
meaningful compared to the the desire
today to just really build up your CV
with with publications when some of
these studies are in my opinion kind of
kind of rushed to to get enough subjects
to publish rather than to get enough
subjects to really to really seek out
the truth ya know I mean there are
plenty of fields where people have won
Nobel prizes with less than 10 or 20
publications you know and you're right
the question is are you doing research
to publish or to answer questions you
know I know that Gregg often talks about
the idea of imposing a limit you know
the idea that if you're a university
professor you're only allowed to be
involved with two published page papers
per calendar year and if we imposed a
limit like that
how much is so instead of chasing more
people would be saying I only have two
publications to work with these things
have to be phenomenal if I want to get
tenure you know what I mean so it's
almost shifting the focus of instead of
how much more can I do how much better
can I do with a fixed amount of
publications I don't know how that would
work
there's upsides and downsides but as a
general statement you know we've talked
a little bit about current issues and in
science and publishing and higher ed now
I'm I'm about to be 28 and I spent the
last 10 years in the university setting
so obviously I support higher education
and research and science and the
publication process but we should always
be open to making processes better you
know what I mean so I've had the
absolute best times in my life working
on research publishing papers being in
the university system I've had basically
most of my life and within those systems
and processes but it's always it's
always interesting to revisit how we do
things and how we might do them better
yeah I I agree I think you know just
being in academia and on the other side
of the desk and and maybe this is holds
true and publishing as well but it seems
that we keep taking this the consumer is
always right in this consumer model to
higher education and and what is that I
think I think in our country especially
because there are so many universities
we really need to it's a philosophical
question what is the what is the role of
higher education and institutions of
higher learning in modern society is it
to prepare young people for economic
production and economic independence or
is it to seek the truth I think once we
can answer that question we can maybe
refine the institutions of higher
education how they're set up and how
learning takes place but until we stop
viewing students
as consumers and once again view them as
students pupils you know trainee yeah
yeah exactly
well Gregg is gonna be super pissed that
he missed this discussion this is like
his favorite thing to talk about but
I'll deal with the ramifications of that
so today I don't know when this episode
goes up today is March 25th 2019
so let's pencil in March 25th 2029 why
don't you come back on and we'll see if
you fixed all these issues in higher
education I might not have a job really
pushed the the protections of tenure
yeah that's what they're there for
I believe in you okay so one question I
want to ask before we go we're really
thankful for your time it's been awesome
to chat I love having you on and
hopefully we'll have you on again one
thing we like to ask people we bring on
all these evidence-based people that are
interested in Fitness interested in
science but a lot of people have like a
thing or two that they do that isn't
necessarily evidence-based so either
they do it themselves or with their
clients or something but something that
either kind of flies in the face of the
current evidence or there's just no
evidence supporting yet is there
anything that you do or that you have
clients do that kind of fits that bill
hmm no I I can't really think of
anything that that that we've done
actually yeah I'll give you one example
and I don't know if it flies in the face
of evidence or if it is an evidence
based but I I had an athlete just
compete in a in the bikini division and
we did cryotherapy a couple days before
her position or her competition excuse
me on her lower body to see if we could
draw out some additional fluid and and
l'm a shinto leave her legs and her
lower body a little more defined whether
it worked or not
I honestly don't know I don't think it
had any negative impacts yeah were you
pushing that or was the client pushing
that she had actually asked about it and
so I gave it some thought and and I
thought that might have been the best
time to use it because icing ice bath
things like that tend to at least blunt
some of the molecular indicators of
adaptation to resistance training so I
didn't want to do it during the during
the offseason or during much of the
competition phase where the inflammation
a little bit of inflammation and the
breeze and everything kind of signal for
adaptation but but I thought maybe it
would be beneficial if we did it right
before the show if we could cut down any
any lingering inflammation I mean
obviously we D loaded and tapered
leading up to the show but see if we
could cut down any any sort of lingering
inflammation to to leave a more harder
to find look especially in the lower
body yeah and so your interpretation was
either a neutral to a slight positive
benefit yeah she she definitely looked
better than came in and a lot better
shape than her than the previous year a
lot more defined and and whether there's
so many factors that that could play a
role in that part of it was just overall
better calm conditioning and a lower
body fat percentage lower body fat but
but whether it helped or not I'm not
sure anecdotally you know you you feel a
little bit better the next day you feel
a little less sore after sitting in a
nice bath so maybe it was mental yeah
could be well yeah I mean it's
definitely something I
there's certain questions with physique
athletes I don't know if we'll ever have
an answer to you know how do you who's
gonna run that study to say oh yeah if
you do a little cryotherapy a couple
days before you look subjectively leaner
I mean that's exactly what we're talking
about some of those things that kind of
fit into the periphery of it's not
necessarily evidence-based but hey
here's the thing that some people do but
today was great so we you know we talked
about betaine we talked about kind of
the state of science and academic
publishing and higher education and
ultimately I think we're at kind of a
starting point of a lot of growth and
maturation in it I think it's all
positive growth and it's good knowing
that people like you Jason are in these
academic structures and promoting these
positive changes so thank you for what
you do for sports science for higher
education and thank you for coming on
and sharing your time with us it was a
blast I appreciate you having me on
I'd love to come back sometime
absolutely Greg's gonna be so upset he
missed this so he'll probably schedule a
impromptu part two at some point that'll
be awesome all right take care all right
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another healthcare
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science comm to check out
the products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you